You've made it to the end of another lesson,
and we've had a lot of new material here.
So let's try to summarize all of what we've
learned into six main points. Point one, mutations in
either the coding or non-coding region of our genome
can be classified as either SNVs, insertions, deletions, duplications
or even chromosomal translocations. Point two, mutations in the
coding regions of genes can be classified as either silent,
missense, nonsense or frameshift mutations. Point three,
sources for mutations include: spontaneous errors during
DNA replication or induced mutations from UV
rays from the suns, or X-ray energy. Point
four, mutations that occur in germ cells
are the mutations that get passed down to
the next generation. And aneuploidy describes problems
in cell division that result in additional or
missing chromosomes. Point five, both allelic and phenotypic
frequencies aren't the same in a population typically. And
point six, both random and natural selection can change
the phenotypic and allelic frequencies in any given population.